[Music]
in baggage claim
Becky means oh there's another cannot
see the manager it's submitted by man
purse murse
it's a murse Delta apologizes for
calling the police on a black woman with
damaged luggage what they call the
police on the victim on a customer yeah
well that's what happens a lot though
why are they accusing her of some shady
[ __ ] this passenger she was on a flight
from Kentucky to Massachusetts when
Arlene was the victim she noticed that
her luggage had been ripped in several
places oh so she's like I know sometimes
they'll get beat up a bit but I still
wanted like I I felt like I needed a
file claim so she goes to the baggage
claim place and she starts talking to
one of the employees there and she was
like trying to fill out the claim she
started talking on the phone with her
friend so then her friend asked who's
that like in the room with her who'd
that be and then that's when Arlene was
like oh it's just a Filipino man oh she
ended up mentioning to her that the
employee was talking to a manager about
her luggage and that's when that
employee was like no one's talking about
you you're out of your mind and then
that's an Arlene said can you please
stop talking to me you're not the
manager and you're being disrespectful
and then that's when the employee
started being even more rude and then
there's a video I can show you today
there's a video it's probably a lot more
that happened not in this video that let
it says that we'll know because it
always halfway gets recorded and then
you hear one side of the story the
others it's just what really happened
yep that's important to keep in mind we
don't know let's just take everything at
face value though yeah yeah that's what
everyone does anyways he's white so she
deserves to be kicked - here we go so
you can't give me the manager on duty
who you called oh wait let me give you
more context is that a Filipino lady no
no so then she asked for a manager
because this employee was being really
rude within a manager a male comes down
talks to her for a little bit he was
really rude and then
he ends up leaving and so now she's
asking like I want your name and I want
his name and his shoes start saying like
well I can't give manager's name in them
yeah well can you give me dizzy how this
is car does he have a phone number okay
well I can wait I can wait for you to
call it that but I would I need his name
for my claim I I need all staff that was
on so I can submit my report is that a
policy to refuse to give the manager's
name no it's not it's a policy they
refuse to give somebody else's name
that's not yours we're not allowed to do
that okay so Kim you call at least can
you attempt to call it if he can't come
Wow I will wait I'll go to the gate but
can you at least caller well can you at
least call them because you can't refuse
to call the manager from acts how you
speak to them but you can't refuse
you can't refuse I mean I think she
overreact
to me that just looks like a regular
customer like if you've dealt with any
type of customer service working at a
restaurant working anywhere if someone
if someone asks to get the manager or
whatever it's like that's what you're
supposed to do and the manager is
supposed to come down and [ __ ] manage
the situation yeah manager shouldn't
leave a situation where there's a
customer like that with those staff yeah
maybe the staff is just trained like and
then the manager gets upset if the if
they have to deal with anything yeah
that's a shitty manager for sure yeah
you supposed to backup your status I've
seen like so much [ __ ] happen like
all over like whether it's restaurants
or whatever and then it's never handled
this way so Arlene is saying that the
manager came and like when he loved was
cuz because he dismissed
Arlene's claim like she doesn't have a
claim like we're not gonna accept it or
the fact that she's complaining against
ten Tedra which is the Delta
she's just like I don't know how but he
dismissed that and so she was very
unhappy about that that's why she also
wanted his name or her report and she
tweeted it out and she wrote in a note
like all her experience and then she
never got any response until another
Twitter account that's more well known
they ended up tweeting that video and
that's when it finally got Delta's
attention okay that's started going
viral that's what sucks but that's how
it happens for everything you get shitty
service if you're just a regular person
like people just pass you around and
they don't want to deal with it yes or
Arlene said that she feels that the
situation was racial she said that if a
white person called the police on a
black person it can end badly
if she was white she may now not have
called the police what was her name like
oh she was
I don't ever hand arlene's the victim I
don't know like missed many situations
where the police get called on a
customer well for recording and I guess
that lady's excuse was like she's in my
face I feel like she was she just didn't
know how to deal with the situation why
would she go straight to the State
Police versus just being like isn't
there airport security right I don't
know give me the CIA right now
especially for example even in like
airports in general even with TSA right
like they're they're not local authority
they're like a part of like airport
police right just like in the movie what
was it okay now oh yeah - yes
[ __ ] yeah you know what I'm
saying so like airport security or
anybody's associated with that like
that's like a whole different branch in
Jersey police stationed at the airport
yes but she was asking for State Police
I don't know maybe she's tripping she
doesn't know do you mean the
firefighters right pretty much trying to
go for it as far as possible you know
what I'm saying to like handle something
that didn't seem like a very as far as
possible situation yeah that's why our
leaves like I would like to know I
should call the police company diversity
training is needed
so once Delta finally got wind of this
they responded to her with this tweet
hi there I am so very sorry to hear that
this kind happened to you rude behavior
of any kind isn't tolerated by our
employees no matter who they are
I will definitely Ford your feedback
over to the appropriate desk for further
review
H s H probably like the person who is
like responsible for the Twitter that
like responded I mean I don't see
anything that would suggest it's
racially motivated other than that she
was black and she was white and she just
didn't want to deal with her because
there was no like I feel like there's
probably a subconscious thing where
people are afraid of black people so
then they see that like type of way as
too aggressive or too like the
communication is too aggressive or too
scary they don't know how to deal with
it so they call the police she wasn't
like until she noticed that she was
recording so I think she was like oh
she's gonna try to like defame me like
all these other airport videos so get
her out of here now like the only way
she can get out of here is with the cops
cuz I didn't even feel like she was
being like rude or extra confident
calm yeah it's hard to assume that
because I remember you know at our
restaurant it was a really [ __ ] busy
time and then this black family had a
they had a lot of people and they
weren't getting seated but other people
were because there were like two or
three people and then they just saw that
like oh man all these white people are
getting seated at the restaurant so like
they wrote this really long email about
how racist we were and then out and I
was like man that's that must suck to go
through so many racist things that now
you're just like so you're so scared
that everybody's racist against you and
I'm like damn man that's it's just not
even what it was it was just poor
planning really busy you know no one's
no one's like all preferential service
it's just like damn it is possible to
just literally be a [ __ ] and to like
not be good at your job and to suck at
confrontation and to all that and not it
not be a black thing but I think there
because there is so much racism coming
out again
now like in the last five years people
are just like hypersensitive yeah oh I
can understand everything's really
sensitive and gentle all right you know
what I what I realized it was it's cause
like I think that now everyone's
actually using the internet versus like
yeah 10 years ago it's all the same it
uh it was like nerds are like just like
very a selected or young people right
but now like moms and dads and uncles
and everybody's on the internet no time
in history has there ever been clear
communication between Americans like it
was always the media that controlled the
narrative of whatever minority said or
what white people thought right like you
say growing up in a very white majority
white neighborhood you didn't even know
like a lot of the stuff that happened
until like recently you know until all
the stuff surface like the like how
minorities felt negatively about white
people and all this other stuff and the
racial tension and all that yeah I mean
I growing up I never personally felt
racial tension because I didn't have any
negative thoughts about black people so
if they did they wouldn't say them to me
and I didn't have them so I it was kind
of like not there for me like everyone
was in their little bubbles not knowing
and now I feel it was really tension
yeah because now it's like now what the
internet is doing is just exposing
what's been existing for the longest
time and if you know like if white
people want to stay in their own
neighborhoods and I guess like be
ignorant to what's really going on to
the rest of America then they can but
now with the internet they can't yeah
because it's in your face and you can't
escape it so now it's like whole [ __ ]
what's going on I think that's what's
happening for sure nothing is different
it's just now it's just being shared
it's like more public that's exactly
what I think is like the Internet's not
changing people it's just making us
expose everything racism or not though
that Delta employee she sucks yeah I was
not a good look and at the end of the
day when you're like representing a
company you're like you're not just
representing yourself so you have to
like conduct yourself to like a standard
that like this multi-faceted huge
company
yeah I think she took it personally he's
being petty she was being petty and
power trip in and she didn't know how to
get out of that situation and no matter
what like that was horrible customer
service how would you would you guys
rather have a horrible customer service
but really fresh breath someone that's
very polite but I was the stinkiest
breath in the world even though the
whole time but you don't have to like be
like at their face right let's say
that's their service have you ever been
around someone that has such bad breath
that they created like this bad breath
cloud I have soon as you just get
anywhere near than what think about like
the people that are like terrible energy
and they create this terrible energy
cloud and you walk away and you're just
like your days [ __ ] ruined oh that's
me sometimes we rather like laugh about
that with my friends like it was crazy
but I got everything I wanted yeah but
then they didn't [ __ ] up your day though
all those freaking wet breath is
temporary you know yeah
but bad energy is like a lifetime
[Music]